bajo Un calor abrasador cientos de miles
de peregrinos ascienden al monte rocoso
de arafat el segundo de los rituales
dentro de la peregrinación del Hash la
celebración musulmana que dio inicio el
domingo por la noche uno de los cinco
pilares del islam tengo una sensación
extraña como si estuviera en el cielo
gente de todo el mundo ha venido aquí y
reza a la más de dos millones de
musulmanes de todo el mundo viajaron a
la Meca en Arabia Saudita para la
peregrinación el miércoles el tercer día
los peregrinos regresan a mina para la
lapidación de los jamarat tres
estructuras de piedra que representan al
y el sacrificio de un animal el
eight alada es celebrado por los
musulmanes de todo el mundo no solo los
peregrinos
el principio del sacrificio es que quien
lo hace divide la carne en tres toma una
para sí mismo da la segunda para los
parientes y la tercera se distribuye
entre los necesitados
en Sudán debido a los dos meses de
conflicto interno muchos no podrán
celebrar el sacrificio
pero no hay dinero no hay ventas todo
esto se debe a la guerra la gente no
tiene ingresos desde hace tiempo Algo
similar ocurre en Irak los vendedores se
quejan de que debido a la inflación las
ventas han disminuido
una persona que salía a comprar
regularmente tres o cuatro piezas Ahora
solo compra una o dos o no compran nada
Solo vienen a echar un vistazo Esto se
debe al retraso en la aprobación del
presupuesto y en la inestabilidad del
tipo de cambio del dólar que sube y baja
el taladas se celebra durante tres días
es el segundo gran festival musulmán en
el calendario islámico después del eital
Fit que marca el fin del ayuno del
ramadán